[Música]
rusia mantiene los bombardeos sobre
ucrania mientras las agencias de la onu
piden que se permita la evacuación de
civiles en medio del caos los ciudadanos
hacen todo por mantener la esperanza les
contamos la historia de dos soldados
voluntarios que se casaron
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
dijo que 17 millones de personas
escaparon de ucrania desde el inicio de
la invasión rusa colonia ya alberga un
millón y el segundo punto de recepción
es hungría tenemos reporte de nuestra
enviada especial a budapest
y eeuu y venezuela confirmaron que una
delegación de altos funcionarios visitó
caracas
washington buscaría alianzas con el país
petrolero de cara a dejar de importar el
crudo ruso pero la casa blanca dijo que
la decisión aún no está tomada
un cordial saludo y aquí están las
noticias desde ucrania en france 24
rusia mantiene los bombardeos contra
ucrania y los ataques se intensifican en
las afueras de kiev donde los
voluntarios convertidos ahora en
soldados luchan para defender su ciudad
en medio de la tragedia de la guerra y
de las pérdidas de vidas especialmente
de civiles algunas historias se resuenan
en un esfuerzo por mantener la esperanza
es el caso de una pareja de voluntarios
que se unió en matrimonio antes de
servir
el futuro es incierto el frente de
batalla no está lejos pero el amor como
la guerra está por todas partes para
alicia y valerie es ahora o nunca para
casarse ciudadanos de a pie hace apenas
dos semanas ahora están listos para
defender kiev pero antes portando sus
uniformes militares y cascos durante la
ceremonia ortodoxa hay que celebrar la
unión yo licia te tomo como mi esposo te
prometo amor y fidelidad hasta que la
muerte nos separe
los declaro marido y mujer los
felicitamos puedes besar a la novia
la alegría es pasajera en una ciudad que
se ha transformado por completo las
intersecciones de las carreteras son
ahora puestos de control los sacos de
arena se amontonan como barreras contra
los tanques rusos
ya estamos acostumbrados a esta
situación alrededor de kiev hay combates
pero estamos preparados para resistir
a sólo 20 km de la capital en el
suburbio de irbin murieron el domingo
varios civiles entre ellos una familia
con dos niños cuando intentaban huir
en los bombardeos de artillería
alcanzaron toda la ciudad los suburbios
las casas particulares los apartamentos
estábamos bajo tierra pero era una
oportunidad para escapar así que cogimos
nuestro equipaje y vinimos aquí en coche
y el hámster es que puentes bombardeados
cuerpos en medio de la carretera
animales en los brazos de quienes dejan
sus hogares los habitantes de irving
huyen de los combates mientras la caída
de las bombas rusas se acerca a la
capital
la agencia de la onu para los refugiados
les dijo que ya son 17 millones de
ucranianos que han huido de su nación
por la guerra y después de polonia
hungría eso es su segundo destino tras
haber sido uno de los países que más se
opusieron a la llegada de sirios en 2015
en esta ocasión los habitantes se han
volcado a ayudar entre quienes tienden
la mano hay decenas de latinoamericanos
informe de catalina gómez ángel y oriol
andrés de galarza desde la capital
budapest
con cada tren que llega a este carril
humanitario de la estación kennedy de
budapest una nueva familia que ayudar la
mayoría son mujeres con sus hijos todas
vienen aterradas por lo que han dejado
atrás y temerosas de lo que puedan
encontrar en esta nueva ciudad donde la
mayoría no conoce a nadie kate es una de
ellas huyó de aquí con su hijo leo de 5
años
sólo en para que las cosas importantes
aquellas que no podemos reemplazar
dos días atrás fueron acogidos por una
pareja brasileña que como muchas
familias en budapest se han movilizado
para dar apoyo
venimos de brasil al otro lado del mundo
pero estamos aquí muy cerca de ucrania
así que todos tenemos que ayudar
30 bis a los suyos que se encuentra bien
su padre es alistado como voluntario y
su madre se negó a abandonar el país
el padre de leo dice que está más
tranquilo ahora porque su hijo está en
un lugar seguro
como ella cientos de mujeres van camino
hacia otros destinos hungría solo es un
lugar de paso
valentino yo ganar keep después de que
la ciudad fuera bombardeada será el
bazar donde compraba comida nos cuenta
se dirige hasta muy junto con su mismo y
tatiana a quien ha conocido en el camino
de hecho yo estoy impresionada nunca me
imaginé ser acogida en polonia o hungría
de esta manera
saben que les espera un largo trayecto
pero siempre hay alguien dispuesto a
ayudar elianis es una de ellas en su
móvil guarda los rostros de las familias
que han acogido en su casa en estos días
ella entiende por lo que han pasado hace
unos años fue ella quien tuvo que
abandonar venezuela muchos llegan en
shock al principio porque han tenido que
salir corriendo literalmente
años atrás con 2.000.000 decidió subían
de la guerra cubría fue una de las caras
oscuras de europa entonces esta vez el
país se ha volcado a ayudar
en nueva york el consejo de seguridad de
la onu terminó hoy una reunión con
unicef su agencia para la infancia y con
ocho la oficina para la coordinación de
asuntos humanitarios instalaron a rusia
permitir el paso seguro de los civiles
en la ciudad de sitiadas los civiles ya
sea que se queden lo que se vayan deben
ser respetados y protegidos
el paso seguro para las ayudas
humanitarias
y los civiles a los civiles se les debe
permitir salir como deseen es muy bueno
saber que hubo un acuerdo de entre
ucrania y rusas sobre los corredores
humanitarios esto
fue bienvenido pero falta que se ponga
en práctica tiene que haber una ruta que
sea segura tiene que haber una
programación para los movimientos
tiene que haber nombres de contacto para
llegar a los convoyes se necesita una
línea caliente y son muchos aspectos que
deben ser tenidos en cuenta para que
estos pasos seguros funcionen el
proveedor de combustible australiano
viva energy anunció que dejará de
comprar crudo a rusia como consecuencia
de la invasión a ucrania la medida llegó
mientras eeuu se evalúa dejar de
importar el combustible al país de
vladimir putin tras una reunión de altos
funcionarios con representantes
venezolanos en caracas el pasado fin de
semana para negocio energéticos con el
país petrolero gobernado por nicolás
maduro no se conocen conclusiones sin
embargo washington podría seguir
adelante con la prohibición de
importaciones de petróleo ruso sin el
respaldo de aliados en europa la casa
blanca advirtió que la decisión no está
tomada
esta es una de las razones por las que
he dado el ejemplo de lo mucho que
nuestras expectativas y nuestras
capacidades son muy diferentes ópticas
wii sports tanto porque importamos un
porcentaje de petróleo de rusia menor
que el de los europeos como porque
tenemos una capacidad mucho mayor para
producir nuestro propio petróleo
por lo tanto se trata de una
circunstancia muy diferente y sin duda
vamos a seguir consultando seguir
transmitiendo dónde están nuestros
planes dónde están nuestros debates aquí
internamente con los europeos frans
previamente le preguntamos a phil y con
son analistas internacionales de crisis
el grup si este viaje tuvo algo que ver
con la intención de washington de dejar
de comprar el crudo ruso
si absolutamente porque tenemos que
recordar que washington no tiene
relaciones diplomáticas con el gobierno
nicolás maduro de hecho reconoce a juan
guaidó líder de la oposición como
presidente mensual entonces
evidentemente este tipo de visita es muy
sorprendente y viene precisamente en el
contexto de la crisis energética mundial
o la potencial crisis en el ejercicio
mundial eeuu está preocupada preocupado
de que los precios del petróleo suban y
necesita suplir o reemplazar el petróleo
ruso en caso de que deje de importarlo
venezuela es una posible fuente de ese
petróleo y le preguntamos cómo sería un
eventual acuerdo con venezuela
ahí es donde empieza a complicarse el
asunto porque si fuera simplemente la
cuestión energética tenemos que tomar en
cuenta que la industria petrolera
venezolana está en el suelo está en el
piso
hace unos años venezuela produce unos 3
millones de barriles diarios ahora
produce menos de un millón y es muy
difícil que esa cifra suba
inmediatamente por otro lado está la
cuestión política porque eeuu mantiene
sanciones contra venezuela
y están condicionadas esas sanciones o
su levantamiento a un acuerdo político
que en este momento no existe y que
tendría que pasar en teoría por un
acuerdo entre maduro y la oposición esas
conversaciones están suspendidas y esta
visita de alguna manera
by pasea como dicen en venezuela es
decir pasa por encima del llamado
gobierno interino de wide o que por
supuesto está un poco disgustado con el
asunto siguen france24
[Música]